pour les femmes cet après-midi la
nouvelle loi fédérale C5 qui permet
maintenant des agresseurs sexuels de
purger leur sentence en communauté était
l'objet d'un tir de barrage nourri à
Ottawa et hier c'est l'Assemblée
nationale qui l'a unanime dénoncé le
projet de loi C5 va à l'encontre des
efforts déployés afin de rebâtir la
confiance des personnes victimes envers
le système de justice questionner à ce
sujet le ministre la médecine a fait
aucune concession vivement on va sauver
la mise en oeuvre de la loi mais mais
c'est tout selon lui il existe déjà des
balises solides la magistrature on a un
système où on donne un certain marge de
manœuvre au juge
au moment de termination de la peine
après avoir entendu les plaidoiries des
avocats dans les faits c'est vrai la loi
C5 permet ce qui est interdit depuis
2007 soit d'accorder une peine de prison
à domicile à un agresseur sexuel mais
selon cette avocat la loi n'encourage
pas les juges à le faire automatiquement
mais s'ils sont pas capables de
convaincre le juge c'est peut-être que
les faits ne le méritaient pas à
l'opposé cette organisme qui défend les
femmes croient que la loi C5 va
contre-courant de tous les efforts
récents du fédéral pour combattre les
violences sexuelles on comprend que la
volonté du ministre c'était de prendre
en compte la surjudiciarisation de
certaines catégories de gens
marginalisés mais il nous semble qu'il y
a peut-être d'autres façons d'y arriver
et que ça envoie un très mauvais message
aux victimes on était saisi hier de la
position de l'Assemblée nationale ça
nous a choqué le Bloc québécois devrait
déposer bientôt un projet de loi qui
exigera la révision de la loi C5 ici
normand Grondin Radio-Canada Montréal